les aboyer 23 ans elles viennent du gard
elle a été la plus jeune candidate de
notre famille politique aux élections
législatives de 2010 est laid aboyer une
minute une minute 15 allée chers amis
c'est un honneur et une chance pour moi
de parler devant vous je tiens à
remercier laurent wauquiez et et daniel
fasquelle pour la confiance qu'ils ont
placée en moi en ce depuis ces derniers
mois
en effet faire confiance aux jeunes
aujourd'hui n'est pas une chose aisée
mais les dirigeants de notre famille
politique sont prêts à le faire
certains que notre génération doit
pouvoir grandir et se faire une place
dans notre mouvement
à paris comme dans le gard je suis fier
d'être à leurs côtés
mon engagement au sein des républicains
est clair et sans faille la jeunesse de
france a des valeurs
elle se lève tôt elle travaille pour son
avenir et celui de son pays
et c'est cette jeunesse que j'ai envie
d'incarner nicolas sarkozy avait dit
lors de son discours de porte de
versailles le 31 mars 2012
vous avez 20 ans vous avez la vie devant
vous et cette vie n'appartient qu'à vous
ne laissez personne vous l'apprendre ne
laissez personne écrire votre histoire à
votre place
personne voilà ce que nous devons faire
cher ami être rassemblées être porteur
d'espoir pour la jeunesse de france
c'est notre mission à nous jeunes
républicains aux côtés de laurent
wauquiez
oui la france a besoin des républicains
la france a besoin de nous car nous
sommes les héritiers des grandes
réformes qui ont fait avancer notre
société
la sécurité sociale sous le général de
gaulle la création du ministère de
l'environnement sous pompidou
l'avortement sous giscard d'estaing sans
oublier bien sûr la réforme des
retraites avec nicolas sarkozy
alors à nous de reconstruire la droite
nous devons prouver que nos élus des
territoires sont plus utiles que des
marcheurs déconnecté des réalités
et or seule la droite est de retour la
droite qui dure tout en mettant une
force de proposition avec un projet
concret pour les français vivent les
républicains vive la france
alors lui vous le connaissez déjà parce
que si vous souhaitez vous aider sur
facebook les réseaux sociaux verlaine
militants engagés en seine saint denis
le parti de nos militants les plus
efficaces sur les réseaux sociaux et sur
internet pour défendre nos idées mais
relève bonjour je suis un peu moins
jeunes eux que les a je pense que c'est
pas c'est pas d'abord la jeunesse qu'il
faut voir autour de laurent c'est plutôt
des personnes de conviction nonobstant
nos différences en termes d'âge
d'origine
c'est surtout envie de travailler avec
laurent pour ce parti qu'on aime tant
alors je tenais à dire une chose je suis
la seine saint denis
je ne représente pas la seine saint
denis j'ai été un peu touché par
certaines remarques qui a pu avoir tout
à l'heure de par certaines personnes de
mon département
je fais confiance à laurent pour pouvoir
régler cela vous souvenez tout ce qui a
à peu près un an on était un peu perdu
égard à la défaite qu'on a connu avec
notre candidat
il fallait remobiliser j'ai fait le
choix à cette époque là avec une
personne qui est dans la salle je vais
pas citer son nom de booster les réseaux
sociaux ce pari a été gagnant parce que
on a donné la force aux gens on leur
inculque l envie de rester au parti
beaucoup partent 1 on a tous vu des
propositions en marche
beaucoup sont partis chez ces
démarcheurs mais la grande majorité est
resté avec nous grâce aux réseaux
sociaux on pouvait pas faire les marchés
parce qu'on était attaqués une égard aux
problèmes que vous connaissez avec
monsieur fillon
mais les réseaux sociaux nous ont aidés
nous ont beaucoup aidés et croyez moi
le numérique c'est la campagne de demain
il est clair que si on ne met pas
l'accent sur le numérique demain
il ya fort à parier qu'on ne verra pas
beaucoup d'élections
dernière chose que je voudrais dire j'ai
parle un peu au nom de la guyane et de
l'afrique
je remercie les compatriotes la guyane
n'oubliez pas une chose c'est qu'en
guyane entend d'immigration mais on a
acquis d'exemple à
saint-laurent-du-maroni ou à maripasoula
on a pratiquement 75% la population qui
est d'origine immigrée
on n'a pas le moins parce que c'est un
peu loin mais sachez que ces territoires
sont beaucoup touché par les problèmes
d'immigration alors je finis en disant
j'ai confiance à laurent wauquiez
j'ai confiance à vous tous et je vous
remercie pour la confiance placée en moi
pas parce que pas parce que je suis la
seine-saint-denis g16 dessus confiance
placée en moi parce que j'estime que
laura s'est rappelé que j'avais un vieux
diplôme de droit et il s'est dit
pourquoi ne pas le mettre en commission
de recours
merci laurent
merci laurent mercier verlaine c'est
beaucoup plus verlaine elle fait partie
de ces nombreux jeunes députés vous en
souvenez monsieur laurent wauquiez quand
vous étiez jeune député jeunes députés
qui ont été vus pour la première fois
l'assemblée nationale en juin dernier
emilie bonnivard chers amis chers
laurent si je devais résumer en un mot
la raison essentielle de mon engagement
parce que c'est ce qu'on m'a demandé de
faire très court
ce serait servir servir mon pays
nos concitoyens nos territoires quelle
richesse et quelle fierté tout
simplement d'être française
à voir cette conscience et s'efforcer
chaque jour avec exigence humilité mais
aussi générosité de contribuer à
redresser notre pays à l'assemblée
nationale à lui redonner le rayonnement
qu'il mérite
c'est vouloir remettre au coeur de notre
société des valeurs solides sont
lesquels aujourd'hui tous ses frites le
travail le mérite la justice l'audace et
l'ambition aujourd'hui c'est peut-être
plus essentielle que jamais car nous
sommes face à un gouvernement et une
majorité que je qualifierais en un mot
d' illusionniste duplicité entre paroles
et actes sophisme effets de manche
permanent voilà ce que nous vivons à
l'assemblée nationale on améliore le
pouvoir d'achat a du style et en même
temps bien sûr il augmente de 4 5
milliards d'euros les prélèvements
obligatoires sur les français
on améliore l'équilibré budgétaire de
notre pays dit il
ah oui et en même temps il augmente de
13 milliards d'euros le déficit de
l'état on aime la ruralité distillats
non pardon ça ils n'osent pas quand même
il crée réellement aujourd'hui 2 france
2 catégories de citoyens une france à
deux vitesses
or nous n'en parlons pas souvent mais la
france est un peuple une culture une
histoire une langue bien sûr mais c'est
aussi un territoire et c'est une
savoyarde qu'il vous le dit un
territoire d'une très grande richesse et
au potentiel incroyable sur lesquels
nous devons miser et que vous
représentez tous ici aujourd'hui notre
famille politique a une chance inédite
celle d'écrire une nouvelle page de son
histoire pour servir notre pays ne nous
trompons pas d'objectif
sachons ans semble retrouver des valeurs
simples mais essentielles de loyauté et
d'union autour de laurent laurent tu
traces devant nous un chemin une voix un
espoir
merci beaucoup nous comptons sur toi et
nous sommes fiers de toi et je crois que
nous pouvons dire nous t'aimons vive les
républicains vive la république et vive
la france
bravo bravo madame la députée maintenant
c'est un militant adhérents depuis qu'il
a 18 ans et depuis quelques mois
sénateur du val-d'oise sébastien meurant
chers amis plusieurs personnes m'ont dit
il ya une vraie différence entre la
politique menée par emmanuel macron et
son gouvernement et celle que nous
aurions mener nous sommes numéro un en
2018 ces 82 milliards de déficit pour le
budget d'edouard philippe 82 milliards
nous sommes numéro un de la dépense
publique en europe
nous sommes passés devant le danemark
c'est une réussite à mettre à l'image de
monsieur macro mieux collant il faut
quand même le faire en matière de
déficits publics
nous approchons les 2200 milliards de
déficit et de dette publique ce qui est
moite dette publique
et là nous sommes 19e sur 19 des pays de
la zone euro dix neuvième derrière le
portugal derrière la grèce dont on me
disait qu'elle est en faillite
19e sur 19 là encore une performance
mais le plus grave le plus important me
semble-t-il
au-delà des chiffres c'est plutôt dans
la vision de la france c'est dans notre
relation au pays ses relations la
culture la france n'est pas qu'une
addition d'individus mais une
collectivité de citoyens avec une
histoire et avec un avenir et vous
trouverez devriez savoir monsieur macron
que celui qui ne sait pas d'où il vient
ne sait pas où il va monsieur mac ou
vous est en marche avec quelques autres
dont certains étaient issus nos rangs
mais pour aller où vous qui avez passé
quatre ans avec monsieur hollande
non monsieur macron il n'y a pas de
citoyen mondial pas de souveraineté
européenne
mais oui il ya une culture française oui
nous sommes nous en acide et dans nos
villes dans nos villages dans nos
régions nous sommes de france et notre
honneur
ce mode on n'entend pas beaucoup parler
notre honneur c'est transmettre notre
culture et notre civilisation à nos
enfants et nous comptons sur toi pour
nous mener à sa prochaine victoire merci
bravo monsieur le sénateur responsable
des jeunes des yvelines flora sa bague
mes chers amis mon engagement
républicain n'est pas le fruit du hasard
si je me suis engagé en politique c'est
parce que ne pas faire de politique
c'est faire la politique de ceux qui
nous imposent la leur oui j'ai décidé de
mettre toute ma passion et toute mon
énergie au service du seul parti de
france dans lequel je crois celui qui
défend la primauté de la personne
la responsabilité la liberté le mérite
et l'autorité rejoindre les républicains
c'est partager la passion de la france
la france du vrai la france du beau la
france du juste
celle que l'on entend jamais mais qui se
bat en silence pour faire vivre nos
valeurs éternelles la france de tous les
possibles
la france qui n'oublie personne la
france qui gagne c'est ça s'engager aux
républicains s'engager c'est faire le
pari de l'avenir
c'est à voir l' envie d'aller de l'avant
c'est avoir une vision et un projet
mobilisateur
sur le plan collectif et individuel
s'engager au républicain c'est refuser
le fatalisme et vouloir faire gagner nos
idées
c'est vouloir un grand dessein pour la
france du xxième siècle et pour tous les
français parce qu'il n'est pas possible
de concevoir le verbe cents l'action
nous devons agir agir pour ne pas subir
agir ensemble avec les jeunes
en participant à l'effort de
construction de notre famille politique
et d'un autre pays
agir pour promouvoir une société plus
unis
plus juste plus attentive au destin de
la condition humaine une politique au
service du bien commun
mes chers amis le débat politique se
nourrit de tradition politique forte
il est nécessaire que nous fassions
vivre nos idées en pointe dans la zone
autres pays et l'histoire des
républicains se construit avec chacune
et chacun d'entre nous nous sommes le
coeur battant de notre famille politique
n'ayant pas peur de ce que nous sommes
et ensemble réussissons pour les
républicains
et pour la france
[Musique]
promis
il ya de belles voix des beaux talents
dans les jeunes chez nous un vol
représentants de cette jeune génération
qui a conquis de nombreuses villes en
il est maire de rillieux la pape
alexandre vincent deh merci beaucoup
cher laurent monsieur le président mes
chers amis
déjà c'est un honneur pour moi de
pouvoir m'exprimer devant le conseil
national pour la première fois le
parlement de ce parti je suis comme vous
un élu un militant même si aujourd'hui
je suis un élu de la république j'ai été
élu à 30 ans maire d'une ville populaire
et pourtant en tant que militant je
continue à tracter à coller comme vous
j'ai déjà discuté dans les marchés dans
les cages d'escalier
aussi je me suis déjà pris des tracts
dans la figure
et pourtant pourtant vous avez toujours
tout donné ces dernières années vous
avez vous n'avez jamais plié vous qui
donnez de votre énergie de votre temps
et vous avez tenu bon puisque vous êtes
ici si nombreux aujourd'hui à soutenir
laurent wauquiez
je suis maire d'une ville populaire de
la banlieue lyonnaise une ville qui
compte trente deux mille habitants et 55
% de logements sociaux dans cette ville
la république a parfois reculé
il ya une france populaire que parfois
nous avons oublié et nous avons déçu
puisqu'elle ne nous regardent plus elle
ne nous a même parfois pas fait
confiance
regardez l'année dernière dans cette
ville je pensais une retraitée qui
habite dans un des quartiers les plus
pauvres de ma commune elle paye ses
charges
elle paye ses impôts elle paye ses
loyers et pourtant les prisonnières de
son appartement parce que des voyous
sont dans la cage d'escalier et ne sont
pas causés par la justice là je me dis
que la république à recullé quand une
mère de famille dans mes quartiers qui
est une de nos compatriotes issus de
l'immigration de confession musulmane
d'un devoir me disant monsieur le maire
je ne mettrai plus mon enfant dans
l'école publique du quartier
je la mettrais dans l'école privée de la
ville parce qu'il n'y a plus de mixité
là aussi la république a reculé
mais cette france populaire cette france
des barres d'immeubles
certains dans les salons parisiens ne
veulent plus l'entendre et voudrait même
la faire taire mais c'est à nous les
élus du territoire cher laurent les élus
qui avons conquis des villes en 2014 qui
devront être cette opposition nous
devons porter la voix de la france d
oublier cette france chaire le rang je
sais qu'ensemble nous allons porter
cette voie nous devons lui parler parce
qu'elle est le coeur de notre pays
donc tous avec une droite de retour tous
derrière laurent wauquiez et longue vie
aux républicains à l'actionnaire